do we have a secret video right now
Prince William serving up some Royal
customer service I hope I've got that
sense of Duty while visiting an Indian
restaurant in central England with his
wife Kate Middleton the Prince of Wales
poses as an employee taking a call from
an unsuspecting customer
after confirming the dining spot's
location William totally Embraces the
part even helping the caller book a
reservation
[Music]
the call ends with the heir to the
British throne and the staff giggling
over the whole thing
somewhere else
after a bit of fun the royal couple
hopped in the kitchen to prepare some
dishes
and took a few snaps with fans and the
restaurant workers
we are on the eve of a coronation the
most important and momentous occasion in
Charles's life meanwhile William's
father King Charles is awaiting his
coronation set for May 6th net is
learning some new details about the big
day this is going to be a very exciting
event for Prince George Who as we know
is now going to have a very Central role
he's going to be one of King Charles's
four pages he will follow Charles down
the aisle in Westminster Abbey and help
handle his robes it's a very key role
and a big responsibility for a little
boy don't forget this is all part of the
training for Prince George who will one
day be king and who will like Prince
Charles when he was that much younger
just four watched his mother crowned
this will be Prince George watching his
grandfather crowned with his father
looking onto knowing that he will be
next while The Prince and Princess of
Wales planned to attend with their three
children Prince Harry's going solo now
we have had confirmation that Prince
Harry will be attending the coronation
alone there's some relief that he's
actually going to his father's
coronation that having been in question
certainly for the past few weeks some
surprise that Harry is going alone not
so much when you realize that it's his
son Archie's birthday the very same day
so Megan is in fact going to be staying
home in California to celebrate that
birthday which is perhaps quite
convenient given the tensions between
the two families right now as for if
this reunion might act as a start to
resolve the Royal Rift I think most
people are optimistic that this
relationship will heal over time I just
don't believe that the coronation is
going to be the place for that to happen
it's just too big of an event it's too
public there's going to be too many
people and too much going on but
hopefully it can be the start some real
long-term healing
foreign